ma guardate un sabato dove finalmente
delle cose da dire e non devo fare per
forza una reactions come mi sono
trasferito da un botto e non ho ancora
finito di arredare casa ho scoperto che
le case non si arredano tipo in the sims
che tu schiacci un tasto ti compare un
menù scegli la cosa che vuoi e compare
magicamente nella stanza lì dove la
volevi precisa ma funziona così quindi a
distanza di un botto di tempo ho preso
la vasca da bagno che non ce l'avevo è
stato un anno senza lavarmi è per questo
che sono diventato amico di pietro
perché siccome lui puzza più di me io
non sentivo il mio d'ore cioè mi è
arrivata la vasca da bagno quelli che
verrà portata
me l'hanno me l'hanno messa nella sala
poi dovevo chiamare l'idraulico che mi
montasser adava scanu da quando me
l'hanno portato a quando arrivato
l'idraulico e passata una settimana io
per una settimana ho avuto la vasca da
bagno in sala da una situazione è questa
quella è una [ __ ] vasca da bagno
se vi fosse mai chiesti come fatta una
vasca da bagno dentro è fatta così
c'è questo è lì l'interno di una vasca
da bagno c'è bisogna essere mai gyver
anche solo per capire che cosa c'è
dentro una vasca la pancia ci sono cose
o cose c'è questo è questo all'interno
della delorean di ritorno al futuro non
è una vasca da bagno però vabbè che
probabilmente quando fanno la doccia
andrò avanti nel tempo un casino
lasciamo perdere che comunque la casa
mia è diventato un cantiere e da quando
è diventata un cantiere cesto vecchio
che mi fissa comunque sia la vasca
dovrebbe finire lì in quel punto solo
che non è facile ci vuole un oretta al
giorno più o meno per muoverle perché
pesa tanto quindi per muoverà mi ci
vuole circa un'oretta al giorno
faccio un centimetro al giorno ho
calcolato che da da adesso fino a inizio
novembre dovrei essere riuscito a
spingerla fino al punto nel bagno ma
andiamo avanti ragazzi volevo parlarvi
di un altra cosa che è successa durante
la settimana l'altro l'altro l'altro
ieri sono uscito con un video senza dire
nulla il video era questo trailer
e alla fine ci ha scritto solo 13 marzo
senza dire niente perché non ho voluto
dire niente volevo voluto vedere la
reazione del web a questa cosa e ognuno
dava la sua teoria su cosa potesse
essere un sacco di gente ha pensato
fosse game therapy 2 cioè come se
potesse uscire un altro game therapy
dopo che la piece zoda sono dove sono
finiti clapis zona alcuni hanno
addirittura ipotizzato potesse essere
una web series tipo scarpi di pai solo
versione fa vj su youtube
però non è neanche quello alla fine ho
annunciato su instagram nel caso non lo
sappiate ve lo dico qui quel trailer si
riferisce a the cage che cos'è the cage
non è un tributo a nicolas cage è un
libro un romanzo che ho scritto
nell'ultimo anno li ho tenuti
completamente all'oscuro di questo cioè
non ho detto niente non ho fatto
trapelare neanche una mezza informazione
non ho parlato neanche la mia famiglia
non lo sapranno anche mia madre
veramente questo perché il mio obiettivo
era arrivare sotto data cioè proprio
all'uscita del libro e dire ciao ho
fatto un libro e ce l'ho fatta
incredibilmente ce l'ho fatta perché non
pensavo neanche io di riuscirci il libro
non è un'autobiografia non è con il mio
primo libro non c'entra niente proprio
un'altra cosa tant'è vero io e jacopo
livieri che è uno scrittore di
fantascienza che ha co scritto il mio
libro ci abbiamo lavorato per circa un
anno e qualcosa è uno dei progetti ai
quali tengo di più in assoluto e ho
voluto firmarlo in copertina con il mio
nome non con la scritta fa vj perché lo
reputo proprio un traguardo incredibile
a grandi linee non vi posso spoilerare
nulla del libro perché sono mondadori
viene qua e mi tira una badilata sui
denti per ogni libro è uno young adult
quindi uno young adult esempio maze
runner hunger games sono young adult e
non vi posso vorrei dirvi in qualcosa di
più sulla storia però non posso
spoilerarvi assolutamente niente volevo
leggervi la parte dietro credo che
mondadori non mi ammazzerà se lo faccio
perché c'è scritto qua quindi lo possono
leggere tutti
se domani non faccio più video è stata
mondadori tra poco la porta si aprirà
riceverai altre istituzioni in seguito
ci sono altri una mente dovete andarvene
da qui o morirete avete 60 ore più o
meno il tempo che ci metto a montare un
video e a proposito di questo mi hanno
chiesto in tanti poi se ovviamente andrò
a fare i firma copie la risposta è sì è
il mio primo firma copie vicinissimo tra
l'altro e
e lo farò il 17 di marzo sabato prossimo
17 marzo alla mondadori del duomo che è
una delle librerie più [ __ ] d'italia
poi i ragazzi il 17 marzo ci vediamo in
duomo che faremo voglio vedere troppo
voglio vedervi tutti per chi verrà in
duomo il 17 marzo a parte che farò una
foto della madonna perché voglio
mettervi tutti su instagram perché
essendo la prima data di prima firma
copie
ci tengo che sia fighissimo e quindi
farò una foto gigante scala metterlo
solista grano e poi sarò veramente
orgoglioso ma ve lo dico con il cuore di
firmarvi ogni singola copia ad ognuno di
voi perché per me essere arrivati fino a
questo punto vuol dire veramente tanto
qua sotto in descrizione vi lascio anche
il link per pre ordinare il libro perché
lo potete già preordinare volendo e
niente raga questo è quanto è stato
liberatorio dirvelo perché è un anno e
mezzo che ve lo voglio dire non riesco
mai a dir vero non posso dirvelo e
finalmente come sfogarsi come aver detto
una cosa che ti tieni dentro da una vita
e l'ho detto maledizione finalmente c'è
veramente uno sfogo assurdo avervelo
detto ovviamente quando arriveremo a un
milione e mezzo di copie vendute faremo
il film quindi se lo prendete adesso in
questi giorni sappiate che quando
raggiungeremo la popolarità mondiale con
the cage e voi potrete dire di averlo
avuto per primi sono contento vado a
spostare di un centimetro la vasca da
bagno perché oggi ancora non ho non ho
dato cosa se i ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come ha suggerito decisamente
mi piace anche vari suo cerchio
nell'esercizio vi ricordo che
d'estinzione lascio il link per per
ordinare il libro sento questi schiette
e noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo visto
dai ragazzi
[Musica]